[Music]
hey you guys time once again for another
matinee now we're cheating a little bit
on this one a little bit I guess because
this movie actually first started making
the festival circuit back in late 2018
and it got released on VOD I believe it
was just this past fall like October or
November of 2019 but we only just got
around to watching it so hell with it
we're gonna review it anyway because
I've actually heard a lot about this
movie and kind of wanted to see it it's
not commonly available anyway yeah we
rented it on Xbox I think yeah and I
think you can get are not Amazon Prime
and stuff like that this is this is
Antrim yeah the deadliest film ever made
yeah considering it to be a new movie so
we'll consider it a new movie yeah
so that's I think you just started
offering in the past month or so yeah so
basically this movie is it's kind of
like a mockumentary but not quite
because the entire thing is an ax
mockumentary it's basically like it has
it's like an Oreo cookie and that the
cookie parts are like the mockumentary
parts which are only like a few minutes
that like bookend the thing and then in
the middle is the actual viewing of the
cursed movie antrum yeah so that yeah so
the whole like premise of this is that
the movie Antrim was actually made in
the late 1970s I think it was supposed
to be Bulgaria or Russia or somewhere
like that and you know the mythology
behind the movie is that you know the
one public showing that they had like in
Budapest I think they said it was the
theater burned down and they you know
figured out that everyone that in the
audience hit either like set themselves
on fire or started a fire in the theater
or whatever and it killed everyone and
then they were trying to like shop it
around to film festivals and stuff and
like every single person that viewed it
like to see if it was going to go and
the festival or not ended up dying and
like mysterious ways so it got like this
reputation of being cursed and you know
if you ever see it you're gonna dive and
then it was like lost for like 20 years
that's kind of like the whole mythology
of this thing and so now like the people
who
made this movie have located it and are
now showing it to you yeah I mean so
that's the whole yeah its documentary
about a fake 70s movie and they show you
the movie yeah and it is like watching a
[ __ ] pretty little bunch of seventies
movie but in a good way I liked it yeah
it seemed like because I've been
watching like some other people's
reviews of it like some people are you
know liked it some people were like man
they didn't think it was very good
um one reviewer that I watched she was
like he wondered if he's like did
somebody just make like a 70s throwback
movie and then decide to add this extra
layer of metal layer on top of it why
did they well not according to the
Wikipedia page apparently this was the
way it was supposed to be structured
like from them because they really liked
the commentary on you know I and I kind
of like this kind of thing too or they
like this kind of I'm not super into
found-footage movies but I like these
kind of like meta-narratives where it's
kind of like here's this curse film and
it's actually real and they make it and
they go to the effort to make it look
like it really came from back then and
then they're like kind of building this
mythology around it so I really dug like
the the whole like um premise of this
and like the whole idea of it and then
the idea of them just showing it in the
middle and then there's like other like
mysterious [ __ ] - they're saying that
well there were frames like subliminal
frames like put in there by like an
unknown third party which like looked
like they were kind of from a snuff film
or something like that you know so so
like I said you know they bookend it
with you know all these kind of talking
heads and like film experts and stuff
like that and they're even like making
reference to other cursed film movies
like the ring and like cigarette burns
from masters of horror that John
Carpenter drives which was yeah I like
that too which was about a curse movie
also so it so it's very like self-aware
in that sense now I will say that you
know I really dug this but I'm gonna say
that if if you're into like weird 70s
movies then you'll probably like this if
you're not probably not because I think
what ends up happening is that they hype
it so much like in the first like so
people all these people died watching it
and they they even have like a 30-second
like legal disclaimer saying hey if you
die while watching that we're not
responsible and yada yada then they do
like a 30-second countdown like so you
can turn it off and all this other kind
of stuff so I will say that maybe that
kind of like builds up expectation like
you think it's gonna be the scariest
movie ever the glorious movie ever um
which it's not but I will say that it
does have a really cool I mean they
really did nail that just weird and I
can't even put my gun don't even know
what the word for this weird low-budget
you know what it reminded me of it
reminded me of let's scare Jessica to
death it had like a tone that kind of
like that because basically the story of
Antrim that's happening in the movie is
there's like an older sister I think her
name is orally and she has a younger
brother named Nathan and their dog gets
put to sleep their dog Maxine at the
very beginning which starts out on a
nice happy note um the dog gets put to
sleep and the little boy is like well
asked the mom like oh is the dog going
to heaven and their mom who was I don't
know why she says it's because she's
just a horrible person I guess she's
like no Maxine was a bad dog so she's
going to hell pretty much so apparently
this is causing the little kid to have
like nightmares and be like really
traumatized which is you know not that's
not surprising
so the big sister decides well we're
gonna go out in the forest and we're
gonna dig a hole to hell and we're gonna
find Maxine and we're gonna like save
her soul we're gonna pull her out of
hell so she they go to this place in the
forest that she's they go camp out and
she says this is where Lucifer you know
fell down from having you to go through
and she had like this grimoire that was
like hand-drawn and it's like had all
the [ __ ] about the different levels and
demons and all this other kind of stuff
but then obviously like all this real
[ __ ] does start happening so it just had
this really kind of cool like unsettling
like I said it's not scary and it's not
gory but it does have like a really
creepy like unsettling type of vibe to
it you know and and it does have kind of
these little subliminal thing like
demonic faces and little demonic sigils
like you know that looked like they're
scratched into the film and that kind of
stuff and then there's like
weird [ __ ] at the end with like these
two cannibals or what are they I'm not
really sure I'm in with like a brass
bowl type thing that's a little strange
but um yeah this is just like I I really
liked I don't know I just I just really
liked the whole Gestalt of this and like
I said you know they were fascinated by
saying like you know because it's kind
of about the power of story telling
stories becoming real or like having
effects in the real world
which kind of comes into play later on
and like I said I won't spoil it
but another thing that they said was a
big inspiration and this should kind of
give you a sense of of where they're
coming from is I don't know if you guys
have seen there's a short film and it's
called dining room or there is nothing
I've seen it because it comes up on a
lot of the creepiest YouTube like type
you know videos where people are like
pointing out like all the really creepy
[ __ ] and this is one that turns up on
that a lot it's a just this really
surreal like short film and the guys
that made this movie said that was also
a big inspiration they just really liked
the whole feel of that and so they
wanted to like kind of get that same
kind of vibe for this movie which I
think they did succeed at but like I
said if you're into just like these just
creepy eerie like you know that don't
necessarily make a lot of sense that are
just kind of like these weird made it
was like just these weird creepy images
and stuff then you'll probably really
dig this other than that I don't know if
you would or not cuz like I said you
know the whole hype at the beginning
does kind of make it seem like it's
gonna be the most horrifying thing
you've ever seen and obviously it's not
no cigarette burns is a very similar
concept yeah yeah but I think cigarette
burns was creepier
it was weirder well this isn't a bad
movie yeah it's just a different take on
something like that yes
cigarette burns I think was more you
know concerned with kind of like gore
because it is much much gory I mean this
is really a symmetry or [ __ ] happen
weird [ __ ] happened and cigarette burns
yeah this one has weird [ __ ] happen but
it's not as disturbing yeah I guess you
could say that
this one is a little more
friendly I guess and a friend I mean
they're neither one of them are you
could you had to pick one to show it
yeah this one doesn't quite go as far as
cigarette burns did and cigarette burns
isn't full feature it's full it's an
hour you know it's still they did
capture the kind of That 70's weirdness
they really did like I said there's a
lot of movies that actually did come out
in the late 70s so we're kind of like
that have this kind of like loan to them
yeah but most 70s movies didn't go this
far well yeah that's true you know had
this come out in the 70s I think it
would have been pretty [ __ ]
well-received
yeah I definitely think so too but I you
know I dig this kind of like throwback
type of stuff though and like I said I
have to say the filmmakers did a really
good job of capturing that I don't know
I mean it looks like it was shot on 35
millimeter and you know so to kind of
give it that authentic thing maybe it
looks tiny bit too good
yeah it's you have been from the 70s by
the way like the kids hair is their
clothes like the way they could just
kind of the whole the way the whole
thing is is very reminiscent of this
Emma Dee's so they did like a really
good job of doing that um and actually I
I would rather that they you know had it
make like a look like a little bit too
new instead of going too far in the
other direction and like putting all
kind of crazy filters over to make it
look like it was old because that
probably would have been really annoying
but um but you know like I said I I
really dug this movie it's just it was
kind of just like a cool concept to me
and I'm always really into like you know
cursed films cursed books I love that
kind of [ __ ] and I especially like stuff
like this that's kind of like a
meta-narrative that's kind of like one
story inside another story and it's kind
of like one thing it's like commenting
on the other so I really like that type
of thing so if you like that type of
thing then you will probably like this
also but like I said don't expect it to
be you know I'm not sure if the
filmmakers really thought they were
gonna like you know shoot themselves in
the dick by calling it the deadliest
don't never made because that's gonna
like hype [ __ ] up for
you know everything but it does it you
yeah but it does seem like it's getting
fairly decent reviews and it did when it
first like went around the festival you
know like I said it's not the most
horrifying thing you've ever seen it's
not the goriest it's not the most
disturbing but it's just like it's just
a nice creepy kind of curiosity I guess
if you're into this type of movie so you
know what I recommend it if you like
that type of thing yeah I would
recommend it I enjoyed it very much and
you liked it that's pretty good you know
so you know that's a kind of our take on
it so your mileage may vary as usual
[Music]